皆さん radiko あさんの事はありますでしょうか世の中にはまあ立候補しいる
普通の子のグーンっていうラジコンが水の上をはせるようなラジコン空を飛ぶラジコン
たらいろんなやつがあるんですけども
そのどれでもないラジコン
ありますコチラヘウォンくらいムーン英語吸ってる方なら分かると思うんですけども
ボールクライマーつまり壁を登る人です
人ではありませんそうもうリクを馳せるのでもなく水を始めるのではなく空を問うわけ
でもない目指したのは壁でした
パッと見は普通の中なぜゴンぽいんですけどもねこれ動画見たんですけどマジ神に登っ
てたんですよそして本体よりもでかいコントローラーが付いておりますなんか僕 dk
だったんでなんとなくあの物理的なんだレットがわかるんですよなったわけですけど
ほんとわかんないですよわかんないけどなんとなくわかるんですけどまぁ壁を登るって
相当困難ですよ物理的な話をするとなんでこれが出て壁を登るが純粋に疑問に思ったね
まず秋前で掘らせていいとも
ライムショック
[音楽]
ブーブーロードなるほど分かりましたこれ電池でていきたいとおもいます
ます
抹茶すっ
はっはっは
わかんないわかんないええええなんで地上の重要なんね
花その意味はよしってきましたこれで動くまであるぞとさっきの風の音が無いかよく
わかんだったけど
ファーなんでこんな唾を起こすんだロケもう硫酸全身をしたらに後ろ受けず買っちゃう
けど
あ
はい
hi o
すごいはい交換俺が逆でした
えっ
by 4 a
あぶゲートんですよ
[音楽]
いやーめっちゃそうだしやすいさっきのなんか変な音はこれ
この音が出ているというと壁登り損な気がするんですよね早速やってみようと思います
ちょっとれ分かりやって透明な透明のか見つかっちゃいますっ
透明な人ってバカですいいと思うんでやってみます本当にできるか分んないけど
はい
[音楽]
4えっすごい
yeah
ああああああ
あああっはぁ
[拍手]
[音楽]
すごい
03さんあああああ優勝今年のおもちゃ大賞決まります今の瞬間を持って大賞お
めでとうございますめっちゃ楽しかった
27歳独身の男性が言っても楽しいっていうことは子供ですがさんと絶対楽しいはず
すごい
俺が強いよ
[音楽]
ハァハァ
壁によって相性があるんだよこれどうやって壁走ってるかっていうとめっちゃ軽いんで
さっき何だかぜ濃度でこれ吸引ば毛穴になってで吸引してるんですよ
壁にビタってくっつくわけなんですけども2窓ガラスでツルツルじゃないですかだから
バキュームで吸い付きやすいんですけどもうちょっとザラザラの神と語ったらサントス
へないんでちょっと上に登り辛いなって気がしましたなんでか
9組出るのが一番いい気がしますそれで今回太平洋の壁をの丸出し今準備じゃねこれで
言って皆さんで鍛えた方や塀
a 多分ラジコンで一つのリモコンで全部動かすことができるはずなんですよねワン
ちゃんこれ一つで全部動かすことができますさっそく開封していきます
えっ
ああああああ
というわけで集めに集めたぞ壁を登るラジコンかすごい数れました
確かな路コンでチャンネルを合わせれば全部一気に動かせるはずなんですよ
とりあえず全部電源つけます
[音楽]
これで全部電源つけたらたぶんワンちゃん全部動くんじゃない
あああ
動いた
モーゼああ怖いなんか全部回転させたら全部回転するかこれいきます
今までは来たでしょすべてのラジコンがこれと水動きます
あってをドラム
ええええっ
というわけでめちゃくちゃウドいいですけど一応全部つきました
[音楽]
これ
ええっ
ウザそういうで売れたんですけど全部これブーン
すぐとするほんと中で壁を走るの大量に
向かっていきたいとおもいますできます
3 day
me
ああああああ
[音楽]
あっはうっうー do
いやーこれなーやっぱすごいなかなかかなりの力使うと思うよ壁に張り付くの
じゃあなんかずーっと聞かせすると山を続きますね
なんでまだみんな来てるの豊田がこれあの1個で遊ぶのが一番良いと思います壁を
馳せる radiko めちゃくちゃなかったです
突破できない壁があるになったら周りを走ってみると思っていいかも知れませんじゃ